you
hi everyone is cheering let's have a
look at a game from 2004 between 13
year-old Magnus Carlsen playing on the
wide end and sip Ernst both players were
international masters at the time a few
months after this game Carlsen would
become a grandmaster a couple of years
later Ernst would become a grandmaster
so this game was from the group C
section of the Corus chess tournament
nowadays it's noted as Tata Steel so
let's dive in and see what made this one
so special
efore by Carlsen Ernst replying with the
caro-kann what variation we have a
mainline Carroll Khan by g3 Bishop back
h4 is looking to trap the bishop that's
not going to happen
Knight f3 ready to centralise with a
punch that shot down he 5 is defended a
push this guy is strong he is exchanged
and one quick point here I know we're
still in middle game mode but I've seen
end games where this instance of fixed
pawns plays a role White has keep in
mind the correct harmony between the
remaining Bishop and fixed pawns in this
case you can see the whites dark square
Bishop in some end games be a pest to
the h6 pawn or even the g7 pawn
continuing we have e6 just getting some
development in now minor pieces coming
out White Queen side castles this should
be seven this is the worst minor piece
on g3 so looking for a knight exchange
knight reposition to e4 Queen a5 a
couple things in mind with this a2 and
h5 a2 is secure don't want to budge with
any of these ponds a3 would be inviting
tactics Queens are excuse me King side
castle going pawn hunting here for black
not be a good choice too risky to take
on h5 because d6 is a sensitive square
so for example and they takes h5 you
could hop in with either piece to d6 and
it's uncomfortable computer is pointing
out Knight d6 this bishop is a killer
you're not going to King side castle and
if you queenside castle you're still not
really safe with this Bishop knifing
into your position so no time to be
greedy
instead development time King side
castle it is
pair of Knights are exchanged 'if I've
is no longer covered so he hops in and
at the same time cuts off the
communication to h5
and a half-open file
gets out of the line of fire and this is
where black now makes a slip on this
move 17
on the surface it doesn't appear like
it's any big deal c5 is the move in the
game there's an issue with this it's
typical to you know strike at white
centre have your third ranked pawn
advance and strike at your opponent's
fourth ranked pawn there's an issue with
this a better move is Queen b6 applying
pressure to d4 and also having in mind a
bishop a3 move but in the game c5 it is
so pop quiz to you what move did
thirteen-year-old magnus carlsen play in
this position feel free to pause the
video okay
in the game we had Knight to g6 how many
of you came up with that one yeah that's
a star move for sure we have a fork
against the rook and Bishop in the game
the knight is captured but just to
quickly point out if this this move is
you know if black replies with rook on F
to e8
I can simply take out the bishop and
then take on c5 and whites up a pond no
no great way to regain the phone
certainly can't take it now you drop the
rook and if you exchanged rooks first
and then tried to pick up the pawn
that's still no good Bishop d6 and
that's painful
so black takes the knight and this now
allows the Queen to sweep in the e6
that's a check cannot block pawn takes
pawn would just pile up on the pinned
rook so the King gets out of the way
goes to the corner and what to do from
here is the idea to simply regain this
minor piece Queen takes Bishop no
instead we have H takes G opening up the
H file white is now converging on h6 why
not pick up the bishop while queen takes
bishop is met with ninety five striking
at the Queen and the bishop the bishop
would actually be struck at twice best
is to take on g6 white is simply winning
here
continuing we have Knight to g8 there's
some serious threats in mind here to
maybe take the bishop one move later
right because Knight to d5 there's all
of a sudden some tricks here this pawn
on g6 is a great thorn and allows white
some made threats on the h7 square so in
the game we have Knight to g8 defending
the Bishop defending h6 but Carlson says
you're not really defending h6 Bishop
takes h6 in what to do
Knight takes well in the game it's pawn
takes but if Knight takes the rook is
smashing through the Queen is taking the
bishop and what are you doing about
Queen to h7 it's already a mate and four
can't stop this so in the game it's pawn
takes Bishop
rook takes pawn this is a lot of
material that white is giving up Knight
takes rook is forced King here is met
with rook h7 game over
so Knight takes rook Queen takes Bishop
only now and once more
how are you pairing this serious threat
of queen h7
seven is best and is the move played in
the game pawn takes knight white is down
a rook about how valuable is this pawn
on the seventh rank all sorts of mating
threats rook h1 queen coming over here G
and H files all covered let's see how
this one finishes up
King to g7 we have rook to d3 let's not
forget this is the lone defender of the
back rank squares and he's now getting a
little bit aggressive it's important to
note we have e1 covered you don't have a
flight Square yet Carlsen doesn't have a
flight Square yet but this is covered
and the rook is ready to transfer it to
the G file
so what's tried here is ripped to d6 you
can't take the bait
get made it rook g3 follows rook to g6
Queen e5 check and what to do from here
king h6 is a million one if the king
goes to h7 it's going to be a million
five but they check a check another
check and the Queen sweeping into g7 in
the game how it played out King takes
pawn queen f5 follows and from here if
the King moves we wouldn't take the rook
with either the queen of the rook but
rather play rook III first so for
example if black played King a 7 we have
to be mindful of this main threat rook
III first and then the King has to make
a move and you could actually take
whichever rook will end up giving check
to the black King next that's now how it
played out though the King did not go
here instead we had rook f6 and a very
picturesque me epaulette mate Queen to
d7 how beautiful is that
this game was actually I looked into it
this was the penultimate round of this
group c-section and this win here
secured Carlsen his first grandmaster
norm so I thought that was a interesting
thing to point out in fact this this
game by Ernst was the only game he ended
up losing in the tournament he finished
second to Carlsen so anyhow feel free as
usual to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below and I
hope you enjoyed it that's all for now
take care bye
you